what we're gonna do with our futures and
how I don't even know what I'm gonna do
if I'm gonna get a divorce like there
were times where it was like kind of
close to home we have to talk about
Desperados because it is one of the
funniest freakin movies that I've seen
in a very long time was it as much fun
to shoot as it was for me to watch um I
would say definitely you know it's a
group of people who are so fun and
talented obviously we were in Mexico
having a wonderful time when you could
travel it sees that we could go places
and we had an amazing time so yeah it
was awesome please tell me you have a
plan to find Jared's room
she has no no she never has a plan it
really shows the level of desperation
that some people will go to for what
they think is love you see you have
found maybe love again I don't know yeah
but prior to that did you have any crazy
dating experiences similar maybe not
quite on the same level as this um I
don't think I've had anything exactly on
the same level which is why this movie
is so hysterical and fun to watch but I
definitely think that you know back when
I was in Middle School in high school I
was obsessed with love and obsessed with
finding love and I definitely did some
crazy things what do you actually know
about this guy he wants kids
he owns a duvet cover what more do I
want I think what I loved also about
this movie is that it's like this group
of three women and they're all going
through something pretty drastic I mean
one is trying to have a baby in can't
one is going through a divorce or
contemplating divorce because their
husbands cheating and then there's
someone who literally cannot find love
is there a storyline that you most
resonated with uh yeah 100% you know I
they kind of like when I producer char
coming to me about this movie they kind
of wanted me to sort of pick between
Kaylee and Brooke and because you know I
have been through a divorce
I've definitely really resonated with
her and just what that sort of feeling
was like and you know I'm definitely not
trying to have a baby so I couldn't
really
it relates to Kaylee quite as much but I
think that's why I wanted to play Brooke
I kind of went through something I mean
not at all like exactly what happened to
her but just the way of like going
through a divorce and that was sort of
resonating with me so she really you
know meant more to me and I'm hopeful
that I did a good job playing her
because I loved playing Brooke I thought
she was awesome was it there peuta kin
away of course you didn't know every
role that I take on and and if you know
you you lived through it yourself in a
way as you're shooting the project or
whatever so there were times where I was
sitting on the bus and Sarah burns and I
are laughing and talking about like what
we're gonna do with our futures and how
I don't even know what I'm gonna do if
I'm gonna get a divorce like there were
times where it was like kind of close to
home and I feel like that's the best
when you could take on a role and allow
that kind of to come out into the
character or something so personal you
know so definitely there were times when
I really related to playing the
character not so much other time so
you're in a Mexican jail what do you
want me to do dwell on that or rise
above it
dwell on it what was it like to make out
with Heather Graham it was oh my gosh so
crazy like actually when I read that
script I was like who are they gonna get
to play on Hill was like Chris Amon and
then they cast Heather Graham I was like
oh my god I've been a fan in the first
verse so long obviously it's she's so
funny and talented and beautiful so I'm
not gonna lie we had a good time on set
that day you know we were all like gods
crazy like how funny is this but it was
it was great I couldn't ask for a better
scene partner and in all ways so yeah I
knew I should have called
this is been way too long I also want to
talk to you about here a while because
it's complete opposite basically then
Desperados you are known for playing
much more I want to say funny comedic
perky roles and then to see when this
was really like a nice contrast I
thought for you what was it like to dig
into something like that and is that
have you ever felt maybe like typecast
in a way that you don't get these
opportunities as much uh yeah that's a
great question I obviously you know
loved playing the roles that have gotten
to play like in the pitch perfect movies
and you know all that stuff and that
blonde bubbly uptight person but I don't
really get scripts sent to me like this
because I think I've played those roles
so many times so when I got sent this I
was like wow they want me to play this
like I'm what this is crazy I never get
stuff like this so I was a hundred and
ten thousand percent ready to rock and
roll and shoot and I would have deeper
no more challenging roles like this so
I'm hopeful that this movie you know
obviously it's an important topic but I
also hope that it opens some doors for
me so people don't see me as this you
know type a blonde that I've been
playing forever and more roles will
hopefully come in that are similar to
this by just creatively I'm a little
tapped out like playing with certain
things so I think I'd rather say no and
even create a role that would be right
for me and more challenging and and just
you know to grow as an actor and there's
only so much you can grow when you when
you play the same role over and over so
we'll see fingers I feel that well then
I might know the answer to this but I'm
gonna ask you anyways I talked to a
Hailee Steinfeld a couple weeks ago and
I asked her about pitch perfect for you
know the fans are always wondering could
you see yourself in a pitch perfect for
you think there's a possibility I would
never say no obviously because it's a
group of women that we known each other
for over seven years you know almost a
decade now what's going on which is
crazy to say yeah a wild I think we
definitely I would do it I would
definitely do it I would play Aubrey you
know forever
because I'm
gotten me you know very far in my career
for a reason and the fans love those
movies so I think that if they wanted it
I would be more than happy to do it
again it's just up to Universal I think
at this point it's so funny you know I'm
gonna pretend that you didn't just say
that so we can still be friends
lifeWise what are you looking forward to
most about kind of getting back to
everything rate opening hopefully
finding a vaccine is there anything that
you or just you can't wait to do um I
can't wait to be with my family um there
are down in South Carolina my sister and
my mom and my dad and I just missed them
so so so much a lot of people that I've
talked to have said that this time has
really put things in perspective and
made them realize what's important and
what's not important what do you feel
like you've learned during this time
where then I think didn't put into
perspective for you I think that I'm for
a while I was a bit of a workaholic um I
was you know going from job to job which
I can't complain about but it really
became like my life's obsession and kind
of goal and where I put my value as to
who I was as a person like if I was
working or not
and because that's all stopped and
slowed down it's really made me think
about Who I am outside of that and that
I have a lot to offer just besides being
on his side and also it's giving me a
chance to slow down and that life is
very precious and not to take things for
granted so it's hard I definitely am a
little antsy um obviously if I'm you
know being honest I'm always like go go
go go go so it's been difficult but it's
also made me just reevaluate things that
are really important this has it made
your relationship stronger do you feel
like because you've had to spend so much
time inside with one another instead of
you know being distracted with all the
hoopla outside yeah it definitely has
you know you kind of see who your true
friends are the people that really do
pick up the phone and do check in on you
you did say earlier when we were talking
that you did find love again so how are
you guys handling date nights in
quarantine oh my gosh well he's an
amazing cook I will say that
so he's definitely you know we we've
kind of done some things where we cook
for the movie we're watching so if we're
watching like an Italian movies we'll
have like Italian food night and stuff
like that so we kind of do like themed
movie dinner things but ya know I I am
very lucky to have found someone and and
thankful that we are doing well amidst
all of this insanity that's going on in
the world even if it's not him just
going back to the hole like this puts
things in perspective do you ever see
yourself getting married again I don't
know I won't say no or yes you know I'm
not he was like no way I'm never it some
who knows I have no idea life is short
you know you don't know it happens so
I'm not saying yes or no I don't know
you're just enjoying the ride yeah
[Music]